you're watching a Valley's most accurate
forecast on 8 news now thank you John
we'll uh track Nicole's progress here in
just a minute let's look at our
beautiful Skies across the Las Vegas
Valley beautiful blue see all that fresh
snow up in the spring mountains up there
at Mount Charleston nine inches up at
Lake Canyon reported yesterday all right
so we've got a lot of 50s out there just
wanted to show you that the winds have
turned to out of the North and they're
mainly light but they are feeling a
little bit cooler for sure a couple of
neighborhoods trying to find some 60s 62
at Nellis Sunrise Mountain the rest of
the valley still in the cool 50s we
started out 30s and 40s this morning and
humidity averaging about 24 percent a
little stronger wind along the Colorado
River Valley today Laughlin checking in
at 63 mid 50s right now for Boulder City
Mesquite at 57 Caliente at 45 started in
the 20s this morning and Tonopah 37 also
started in the 20s it was teens up in
Ely 33 there are now probs at 55. here's
our headline sunny skies below normal
temperatures near 60 degrees for highs
Mornings in the chilly 30s we'll get
some high clouds around for Veterans Day
but otherwise we'll stay sunny today and
the weekend looks good too another
system into the Pacific Northwest and
our storm is bringing blizzard
conditions to the Northern Plains and
look at those chilly teens and 20's up
north very warm across the Southern
Plains and let's zero in on Nicole which
is still just barely holding on as a
tropical storm but still swamping
Florida and is rolling up into Georgia
with heavy rain and still some strong
winds it will continue on a path up into
Georgia and the Carolinas into Friday
and Saturday as a low pressure system
we've got a lot of sunshine with high
pressure today again tomorrow we'll get
a few high clouds 60 degrees our normal
high is 70. temperatures really don't
change as we get through the eight day
forecast well below normal afternoons
and those mornings in the very chilly
30s feels more like December John than
November hopefully everybody's heaters
are working and if you haven't checked
it you might call for a tune-up